[MUSIC PLAYING]
FILIP: Welcome back, everyone.
This is, again, this is your
favorite host of "Flutter
Boring Show," Emily
and I. And we are
very impressed with our work.
We like the app that we have.
EMILY: Quality.
FILIP: Yeah, the
quality is amazing.
And we hear that
there is a drought
of apps on the Play Store.
EMILY: Demand is just
through the roof.
FILIP: Yes.
They're calling
Google like, when.
So we are going to fill
that gap by publishing
our Flutter "Hacker News"
app to the Play Store.
EMILY: Disrupts the "Hacker
News" reading space.
FILIP: Next episode
is going to be
about startups and investment
and stuff like this.
So we have our app.
It has caching and everything.
It's a regular Flutter app.
Now that I think of it, we've
been only testing it in iOS.
I'm only hoping that
it's also working
for Android, because we're
publishing it to Play Store.
So how do you do
something like that?
There's actually a
really good article
at flutterio about publishing.
Maybe I should just use Google.
So flutter publish.
EMILY: Good thing our employer
is good at finding things
on the internet.
FILIP: Right, so this one.
As you can see, I've
seen this recently.
And this is all you need.
Let's go through this quickly.
I have done this recently,
as I mentioned before.
And I think, all of this
should be pretty good.
So review the app manifest.
This is the Android
instructions.
App manifest is located in
Android app source main.
So we're going to Android.
What did I say?
EMILY: App source main.
FILIP: App source
main, Android manifest.
So this is the name
of the package.
Verify the values, application,
edit the application tag
to reflect the final
name of the app.
Where's that application?
Oh.
So the label's probably
something like--
I don't know if that's a
trademark or something.
So H- N app in Flutter.
Oh, Flutter HN.
EMILY: By Phillip the great.
FILIP: User permissions--
do we need internet?
Yes, we do, and we have it.
So that's done.
Review the build configuration.
So we need our
application ID that's
unique as our app ID
in the Android app.
So that's not this.
Build gradle.
And we get to default config.
EMILY: [INAUDIBLE] up.
FILIP: OK, we can use that.
We can live with this.
Yes, our own unique
application ID.
EMILY: Do we need to
register it or anything?
FILIP: I don't think so.
I think it's just
needs to be unique.
We'll see.
Version code, version name.
Specify the internal app
version number, and the--
consult the version
information guidance.
Version name, version name.
OK.
min SDK, it should work on
everything, including SDK 16,
so it's great.
Launcher icon, we have the
regular Flutter Launcher icon,
so we're not going
to add a new one.
It's going to look
ugly, but that's fine.
Signing the app, this is
actually pretty complicated
if you do this for
the first time.
And also, I don't want to--
I trust you, but I'm
not going to show you--
use my keys.
EMILY: You don't really
trust the internet.
FILIP: Yes.
So I'm going to go through
these things very quickly.
And we either cut to the end--
EMILY: And I will distract you.
FILIP: Yes, you will distract.
Thank you.
OK.
EMILY: So while
Filip is doing that,
I notice actually a couple
of other little tweaks
that I think we should
make in the future.
Or maybe while Filip is doing
that, I'll do it a little bit.
Right now, it looks like--
I think when I
did the animation,
I had it always
appear, just so that we
could see what was
happening and debug it,
but then we never took it out.
So now that little icon
[INAUDIBLE] is always there.
And I was noticing,
so it should just
be we have this comment if
the snapshot is loading,
that stream of like,
are we loading or not--
in fact, I'm going to
rename this from snapshot
to loading because I
think that's a little more
descriptive.
And then, I'm going to
fix the indentation.
And-- oh, great.
And because I don't trust
my hot reload right now
I'm going to load it again.
And next episode, you
all are in for a treat
because we are going
to bring in someone
who actually knows
how to make apps
look pretty, and is going to--
you can see how we take a
basic looking Material app
and make it better.
We still have a problem.
OK, Filip feel free to
cut in whenever you're--
FILIP: No, I'm still-- thank
you for covering for me.
EMILY: OK.
That's a long error.
What's going on here?
Build functions must
never return null.
So OK, that's right.
So right now, we're
saying if it's loading
return this fading transition.
Otherwise, we're
not doing anything.
And it's saying,
you can't do that,
because it shouldn't be null.
So instead, I'm going to return
a very exciting container,
if I spell it right.
So now, if I tap on
this, there it is.
You get the little Y
Combinator popping up.
And actually, now, because
we implemented caching,
you don't even see it at all.
So we could add it in
briefly to make it appear,
but yeah, that's a little
animation clean-up.
FILIP: Still not
there, but I think
I am done with the
sensitive stuff.
So as discussed before, I had to
create this key properties file
with a lot of secrets.
And then I can go to
android/app/build.gradle.
So android/app/build.gradle.
This is, by the way, I
always get tripped up,
because there's two build
gradles and one is an--
anyway.
And then, it tells
me replace this
with this, which is basically
using my file from earlier
with the secrets.
And then, I also replace this
with this, so build types,
where's build types?
It's right here.
OK, and then, [INAUDIBLE]
enabling Proguard,
we don't need to.
Building a release APK--
EMILY: That's really if you just
want to obfuscate your code.
FILIP: Right.
EMILY: And we're
open source already.
People can see it.
Who cares?
FILIP: So now,
flutter build apk,
that by default is in
release, and fingers crossed.
EMILY: So yeah, this
is actually building it
down to machine code.
And so if you run
this version, you
won't be able to do hot reload,
because we're not running--
FILIP: Yes.
Yes.
EMILY: But it's going to
be super fast as a result.
FILIP: Right.
If you want to get
closer to this,
you can run this
in profile, which
is this button I'm
running now, but actually,
let me just close this.
But with profile mode,
it's very close to what
you get with release mode, but
it isn't signed with the things
that you need for
actual release.
And it has some instrumentation
for doing profiling.
So that's the closest
you get for that.
Otherwise, you know,
everything else is the same.
And as you can see,
we're assembleRelease.
EMILY: Waiting on gradle.
FILIP: Yeah, building gradle.
Looks good.
EMILY: And were there any
other-- oh, you're good.
FILIP: Yeah, we're done.
We're done.
So I can open this--
and now I have 6.7 megabytes of
things that just do, you know,
so you see that the debug
release is 30 megabytes.
So don't get ever scared about
the size of your debug build.
It's always going to be much
bigger than your actual build.
And our 6.7 megabytes
that includes,
I think, the icons
and some other stuff.
EMILY: And I will say the
photo team is actively
working on reducing the size
of even that release APK,
so it's 6.7 megabytes
right now, but it
is continuing to go down.
FILIP: Yes.
OK, so I went to the Play Store.
We're not going to go
through like creating
a user in the Play Store
or anything like that,
but we have our Flutter HN app.
It's going to
default to English.
And then, short description,
it's HN app in Flutter.
Yeah, right?
And, oh, we need assets.
OK, so that's maybe going
to be another intermission,
because we somehow need to--
EMILY: Screenshots.
FILIP: Screenshots
is the easier one.
Let's do screenshots.
EMILY: How many do you need?
FILIP: Two screenshots
are required.
That's fine.
OK, so you know what?
EMILY: Yeah, really quick.
FILIP: We're just going
to do a quick Android.
Maybe the screenshot
in iPhone would not
work for the Play Store.
EMILY: I think people will
appreciate if it's an Android.
FILIP: Yeah.
So let's run it.
This is going to run it in
debug mode to be honest.
So not great, but, you know.
By the way, we're not
actually releasing it
for public consumption.
We're going to release
it for private beta.
We're just trying
to show you how--
EMILY: The process
of how that works.
FILIP: Yes.
OK, so phone, then the icon.
Where do we get the icon?
OK, so--
EMILY: Do you want
me give you an icon?
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: Do you have it?
EMILY: I have like a--
I can make it.
Well, I have a dash icon.
Or do you want the
Hacker News icon?
FILIP: No, dash icon is great.
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: Yeah.
And then, 1,024 times 500 PNG.
This is, obviously, this is
just getting the app to there.
I'm going to go through
the rest of these things.
So it's an application
in the category of News.
EMILY: Is there a
limitation on size of icon?
FILIP: No, well, I will
need a 512 to 512 size.
It needs like an exact
size unfortunately.
EMILY: OK.
FILIP: Oh, I need
a questionnaire
on content rating.
That's just my things.
Privacy policy.
OK.
Right.
I just want to do app releases.
OK, so and maybe we can just
postpone the actual images
and stuff like
this, because I can
imagine that a lot of the
things will be-- oh, this
is super cute.
So I don't know if we're
going to do that like, fully,
but at least I want to show you
how you would like upload it
to the Play Store.
So as I said, this--
EMILY: Will it allow you?
FILIP: --not going to--
yes.
This is not going to be
a production app yet.
So we're going to use
the internal test track.
And the internal
test track is great
because it is only open to
people who you will give
the email addresses to that.
It needs to be less
than 100 people,
but whenever you make
a change, their app
will update in something
like five seconds, or maybe
a minute or five minutes.
So that's really
helpful, especially
if you want to test it on
your own device as well,
and you want to see like how
does the production app look
like with everything.
Then you use the
internal test track.
So I'm going to click Manage
here, and create a release.
And-- reuse?
OK.
Continue.
And now, all I need
to do hopefully,
is just put this here.
EMILY: So there were two--
there was two APKs I saw.
Sorry, go back to your--
FILIP: Right, yes.
So this is the debug one.
This is the release one.
And then, I think this is just--
this is the same
as the debug one.
It's just like a
sibling or something.
But yeah, you definitely
want to put that release one.
Even if you even
try the debug one,
it will just scream at you
that this is a debug one.
So OK, oh, another thing
that I wanted to show you
is whenever you
release to the store,
you need to have a different
release name and release
number.
Right?
We have a version code
one and release name 1.0.
This is actually coming from--
EMILY: Our pubspec?
FILIP: Yeah, I thought it's
coming from our pubspec,
and I don't see it here now.
EMILY: Yeah, I thought
you specified--
FILIP: Yeah, maybe
this is a new pubspec.
And this pubspec that
we're using for HN
app is coming from,
you know, [INAUDIBLE]..
EMILY: I think you
just specify a version.
Yeah.
FILIP: OK, so this
would be 001 +1.
The +1 is important, because
that's what this is going
to be.
Right?
So at some point, you could have
like +8 and still have a 001.
EMILY: So why is
it not version 1.0?
FILIP: We could do that in 1.0.
You can do whatever,
but yeah, all right.
Yeah, I mean it's pre-release.
EMILY: Oh, I see.
I see.
OK, then don't do 1.0.
FILIP: OK, so--
EMILY: 1.1.
FILIP: OK, so now, we
have to actually rebuild.
So let's do it again, because
that's what actually--
so Flutter will update some
of the gradle things that
will make it sign as that.
Right?
Hopefully, this time it's
not going to be 40 seconds.
So then, yes, so we're done.
OK, so we actually
want to use this one.
EMILY: Oh, no.
FILIP: You need to use
a different version
code for your APK,
because you already
have one with version one.
See?
So even though we
didn't publish,
we just need to do this.
EMILY: Oh, my goodness.
FILIP: Yeah.
So this is why many people will
go with continuous delivery,
something like fastlane.
And again, if you
go to flutter.io,
you will find a good
article about how
to do this automatically on
both stores, and continuously,
but again, for testing
and for small apps,
you might just want to use this.
EMILY: Do a one-off thing?
FILIP: Yes.
EMILY: Do you need to rebuild?
Or did you rebuild?
FILIP: Hopefully, this
is the one that-- yeah.
Really?
EMILY: I don't know
if you actually
rebuild after you saved.
FILIP: Oh, I didn't?
EMILY: Yeah.
FILIP: Also, probably do this.
OK.
With another file.
EMILY: Come on
Google Play Store.
FILIP: Yeah.
EMILY: Take our APK.
Seriously?
Wait, so did we
already upload one?
FILIP: Yeah, we did.
EMILY: Can we just use that?
FILIP: We could.
Yeah, I know.
EMILY: If we wanted
to show the process.
FILIP: Yeah.
So no, so this is basically,
you have a release
that's been rolled out.
Yeah, I mean-- yeah,
let's not dwell on this.
Like you would have to rebuild
it or create a new release,
but for now, we just
have version one review.
And then, you should
provide release notes
for every release.
OK.
So initial release.
Please [INAUDIBLE].
Review.
View warning message.
Will not be available
to any users
because you haven't specified
any testers for it yet.
OK.
And then, I could add
at least me as a tester,
and so on and so forth.
So from now on, it's really
just like procedural things
like, adding testers.
EMILY: So where do
you add the testers?
FILIP: Oh, yeah.
EMILY: Is that something
we can click through?
FILIP: This is this.
EMILY: Ah, OK.
FILIP: Right?
So you just add
emails and all this.
So yeah, I mean,
it takes its time.
And for the first time you
will have to get screenshots,
and you will have to get
icons and stuff like this.
You will need to go
through all this process,
but after that, it's
really just like copy
pasting, or dragging and
dropping your latest release
version.
And it's signed
completely automatically.
And it's just Flutter build APK.
And that's it.
A similar process for test
flight for iPhone, and maybe
at some point we could do
that, as well, but not today.
So yeah, we've released,
almost released,
our app to Play Store.
I think it's doing great.
And I think that's it for
today's episode of the Flutter
Boring Show.
EMILY: Thanks for watching.
FILIP: Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]